hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge
feed the beast zusammen mit Simon AK
gespielt und ich habe hier oh ich habe
hallo ich w grüß machen schieß mit du
weißt genau wie die letzte Folge
ausgegangen ist dass du fast gestorben
wärst wegen dem Ding aber si richtig
krakenarm und zwar in der letzten Folge
habe ich ja auch in der letzten Folge
dann gesagt war alles ziemlich
kompliziert weil ungespielt dann 30
Minuten lang bei mir allerdings nur
Minuten allerdings gab es da die Sache
dass das bei mir abgeschmiert ist hey
und deswegen habt ihr paar Sachen nicht
mitbekommen wie z.B weiß nicht was hate
ich denn dass die Diamanten hier
gefunden hab zwei Diamanten und so et ja
zwei Diamanten nur le nur ein oder habe
ich noch mehr nee mehr habe ich nicht
ich habe einfach nur erstmal das beste
mitgenommen und zwar haben wir uns jetzt
gedacht dass wir das hier so regeln
werden habt uns ja fleißig Dinge
geschrieben und wir haben uns das jetzt
mal wirklich zu Herzen genommen und
wollten uns erstmal also ich wollte mir
eigentlich erstmal das Haus zu Ende
bauen allerdings meinte da eine Person
namens The real Semmel danke an dich
sehr sehr cool so wenn das alle so
machen wie er dann dann wärden wir echt
eine geile Community und zwar er ich bin
runtergefallen hat er mir per Nachricht
gesendet dass ich ein maerater Generator
und electric furnace machen soll und
wenn ich die irgendwie nebeneinander
packe dann kriege ich doppelt so viel
Ärzte oder so raus so das versuche ich
zu machen und der Plan für genau jetzt
ist erstmal dass ich nach Hause laufe
ein Portal hier setze genau da und ein
Portal zu Hause dann kann der ungespielt
ganz einfach gleich seine Kisten alle
mit rüber nehmen und ich soll hier
alleine bleiben oder was du kannst noch
bisschen Sachen fahen also das Haus ist
600 m von uns zurück ich bin aber TR
wenn du mich alleine
lässt lass mich nicht zurück hast zu
essen ich habe genug zu essen aber wenn
du jetzt gehst wirst es bereuen
vielleicht nicht heute vielleicht nicht
morgen aber irgendwann geh was zu essen
ach so ja aber ich habe leider kein
Fleisch ne ich habe nur ach Vegetarier
ja warte dann schmeiß er ganz kurz meine
Schaufel weg damit ich hier was aufn
übrigens die facecam ist wieder an also
sorry dass die letzten drei Folgen oder
so keine facecam gab WD gelöscht und
jetzt ist wieder alles in W ja genau das
allerbeste war ja auch er meint so ja
jetzt ist geil dass ich facec hab Stelle
genau da war diese perfekte Stelle mit
dem Zombie ne und genau da war die
facecam gelöscht und dann war dieser
Zombie da ich hätte ich hätte für diese
Szene ich habe mir schon überlegt ob ich
das ob ich diese SD-Karte recovern lasse
für 20 € be so bei so einem Anbieter
aber nur für dies sene nur für diese
Youtube wert das ist wirklich wirklich
also so okay ja dann musst mich jetzt
alleine lassen na toll ja also noch mal
alle die die es nicht verstanden hab bzw
bei den Gehirnzellen irgendwie im Kopf
abgestorben sind nein wir haben euch
alle lieb
ich laufe jetzt nach Hause ich habe
schon wieder eine neue Höhle gefunden
ich lauf nur nach Hause setze zu Hause
ein blaues Portal ein oranges Portal und
in der Höhle
ein blaues habe ich ja gerade schon
gesetzt und dann können wir uns da immer
hin und her teleportieren was denke ich
erstmal ganz sinnvoll war weil in der
Höhle noch lange nicht alles entdeckt
ist weil dort auch noch Minenschächte
waren und alles mögliche da können wir
auf jeden Fall noch uns eine Menge ähm
Sachen später holen das glaube ich auch
und ich habe noch eine Sache die ich
sagen muss ganz es gibt immer wieder
Leute die sagen immer ständig in den
Kommentaren hey ihr spielt jetzt viel zu
Beast macht aber noch gar nicht weiter
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen erstmal
klar wenn wir das VI spielen wollen
natürlich auch viele Leute was darüber
lernen ich finde aber wir haben zwar
jetzt noch nicht so mega viele Sachen
aus diesen technischen Kram gemacht aber
das liegt erstmal daran weil ich z.B
also im Gegensatz zu concraft habe ich
ist das ein mein allererstes ganz
normales let's play Minecraft weil ich
habe sonst nur PVP Kram in Minecraft
gemacht und ich bin totaler blutiger
Anfänger und das ist das erste was ich
so an Erfahrung sammel im ganz normalen
Minecraft Spiel eigentlich und das S
direkt noch mit so zu vielen Mods und
das ist wirklich umfangreich also lasst
uns wenn wir es diese Folge nicht
schaffen irgendwas elektrisches auf die
beell nicht diese Folge sondern diese
aufnahmeession so die nächsten 10 20
Folgen ich habe es ja auch am Anfang
gesagt ne also es ist jetzt nicht mein
erstes Let's Play ich habe schon öfters
mal hier so blablabla bisschen dies das
anderers und so aber es ist auch das
erste Mal dass ich irgendwie mit mich
mit feed the beast bzw so Technik
modpacks bzw allgemein mit modpacks die
umfangreicher sind auseinandergesetzt
habe und folgende Sache ist dabei
einfach entstanden und ich habe dann
einfach jetzt letztens auch mal gesagt
dass wir uns erst am Anfang mit den
ganz normalen grundlegende Sachen
beschäftigen werden wie z.B erdsuche
oder Hausbau und sowas alles und nicht
sofort in die Materie von FE Beast
einsteigen wollen weil es uns einfach
noch im Moment viel zu umfangreich ist
und wir uns da einfach noch
Stecker reinarbeiten müssen deswegen
haben wir euch auch gesagt dass wenn ihr
Tipps wisst zu feed the beast bzw
allgemein zu irgendwelchen Mods die hier
drin enthalten sind einfach am besten
per Nachricht schreiben weil kom oder
halt Kommentare aber Kommentare ist halt
immer so ein bisschen begrenzt
und ja also es wird kommen aber wenn
wenn wenn Leute wirklich in die
Kommentare schreiben hey wann macht ihr
denn mal hier so richtig mit FZE Beast
dann auch wenn ihr das ihr wisst das ja
jetzt wenn wir das hier gerade gesagt
haben dann einfach da drauf an Antworten
und dann mein ja die haben doch da und
da gesagt dass sie das und das dann und
dann machen werden und bla also nett
Antworten und dann passt das schon und
dann werden wir damit doch mal
irgendwann an anfangen und ich werde ja
auch diese Folge jetzt ist mein Skype
hier gerade abgeschmiert an alle die
gerade bei mir zuhören ich weiß nicht
warum das ist wieder ungespielts
Internet weil der Server läuft das ist
immer so immer wenn wir aufnehmen ein
paar Minuten später schmiert hier
einfach seine komplette connection ab
gleich ist er wieder da also was ich
sagen wollte bitte nicht rumeschweren
das ist macht nicht alles besser wir
werden schon noch anfangen mit feed the
beast deswegen ist es ja auch kein
Projekt was nur s geht wir sind jetzt
schon bei 30 glaube ich ungefähr oder 23
oder irgendwie so um den
Dreh aber wir werden uns damit
auseinandersetzen und einfach abwarten
Tee trinken oder Bier was ihr wollt Tee
finde ich in letzter Zeit sehr
interessant bei dieser t Jahreszeit hi
du warst es wieder weil du bist auch vom
Server geflogen ja schön ich liebe mein
Internet ja war letztens auch wieder so
letztens war es auch schon mal so ja ich
versu mich gerade zum Server zu
connecten bin jetzt übrigens zu Hause
angekommen ich werde jetzt einfach hier
so ein Portal setzen in dem Haus das was
du da das abgerissen oder wie J das hast
Du abgerissen ich weiß nicht W was
passiert hier ich versuche mich die
ganze Zeit zu verbinden aber es passiert
einfach nicht ich habe jetzt hier ein
Portal gesetzt und da hinten aber ich
kann da nicht durchgucken ich weiß nicht
hä ich kann mich nicht verbinden ich
kann mich nicht zum Server verbinden
kannst dich nicht zum Server verbinden
doch anwelden jetzt boah nach Ewigkeiten
bin ich wieder da okay ich verstehe
nicht ich trau mich nicht daurchzug
gehen Ich Lager erstmal ganz kurz Sachen
ich geh dadurch ich geh durch okay
kannst du das denn
oder läuft du da gegen ich kann schon
wieder keine Kisten öffnen und so ne
hörst du mich noch ja ich höre dich ich
kann keine Kisten lädst du gerade ein
Video hoch oder wie nein ich ma gar
nichts ich ma gar nichts nebenbei dann
ist es seh sehr sehr Dings komisch sehr
sehr so jetzt oh es hat gerade einfach
nur richtig verzögert nee es der der der
Server lag der Server lag okay jetzt ich
glaube jetzt geht ich gehe jetzt hier
durch mit sieben men geh ich hier durch
wenn ich jetzt
als lebendige Möhre hier rauskomme dann
dann bin ich mit dem Portal also ist
Portal Zeitverschiebung passiert okay
wir wissen natürlich alles was er meint
und ich geh rückwärs durch damit ich
nicht so viel Angst hab oh ich bin durch
wo bist du rausg du hast nicht geguckt
du hat geklappt ja ich bin hier hallo
alte ich will auch ich dachte da kann
man durchgucken oh mein Gott es
funktioniert du stehst bei mir hinten in
der Ecke echt krass bei mir gerade der
Server lag ja also bei mir stehst du no
an der Kiste das Lied dann also bei mir
läuft alles super und ich lade auch
gerade nichts hoch und ich bin das
einzige was ich gerade offen hab ist
Skype FRS Audacity feed the beast und
halt
ja geh im schn flüsig jetzt se ich
flüssig ja es kan sind saisonale
Schwankungen hier in dem Bereich das
eine lagige
Phase so bist wieder abgekackt nee nee
ah okay ja aber ich boah ich kann die
Kiste nicht öffnen und nich boah also
irgendwie also bei mir ist gerade nicht
so so richtig spielb vielleicht sollen
wir nach diesem Part mal ganz kurz
gucken woran das liegt damit das sich
nicht jetzt durch diese Parts zieht okay
können wir gleich mal ganz kurz gucken
ich ich versuche hier gerade erstmal
irgendwie meine ganzen Kisten hier
aufzubauen ich habe ja noch wieder nach
Stunde geöffnet und jetzt habe ich
wieder drauf gedückt jetzt öffnet s
schon wieder dich Bo dann öffne einfach
keine Kiste s mach andere Sachen erst
ich will meine Sachen rübertragen in
mein zu meinem Haus musst du warten aber
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt also ich
kann da jetzt ja eigentlich auch nichts
anan ändern auf jeden Fall klappt das
schon mal mit der mit der Portal Gun was
was in mich eigentlich sehr erfreut weil
wir jetzt immer von von A nach B uns
teleportieren können ich will auch eine
Portal Gun und weißt du was ich möchte
ich möchte Schuhe als Obsidian da kann
man nämlich mit überall rumspringen und
Krieg keinen Fallschaden habe ich
gelesen als ab ja und dann kann man
nämlich sich überall einfach durchs
Portal fliegen man kann nicht durch
Fallschaden sterben ich gehe jetzt euch
veral mit dem ganzen wertvollen Kram ne
wenn was ist dein was ist dein crafting
Rezept was das Crafting Rezept für die
Schuhe ich guck mal ganz
kurz ich wollte euch allgemein jetzt da
wir schon am Ende des Parts wir werden
die Parts jetzt übrigens immer 10
Minuten lang plus Intro autro oder was
auch immer da machen jetzt nicht
rumhulen nur 10 Minuten bekomment
täglich ein Part es ist für uns besser
weil er ist macht Ausbildung ich ma
Schule Facharbeit vorablausuren etc und
ja einfach momentan einfach wirklich
stressig so und 10 Minuten finde ich für
jeden Tag ein Video ist auf jeden Fall
drin ne und dann gibt da auch keine
Schwankungen zwischen uns beiden und so
weiter also ich lese e ganz ganz schnell
eben noch in diesem Part die Dings vor
die Nachricht von the real Semmel und
zwar lieber Kny Reimann wollte dir ein
pa ein paar Tipps geben damit du
schneller Fuß fängst ärzete die du nie
kaum brauchst xyorum brauchen wir nie
das ist nur zu Deko Aluminium brauchen
wir nicht Ember brauchen wir nicht und
Monat brauchen wir nicht und erste die
wir immer brauchen ist auf jeden Fall
Kupfer spter später wertvoller als
Diamanten dann tin auf jeden Fall Eisen
Redstone Kohle Kohle ist auch sehr
wichtig Gold ist wichtig Charts für
Traum Traum Traum trumcraft heißt es
trumcraft ist es wichtig da hinten steht
gerade so ein Enderman ich versuch
einfach mal zu töten dann kriegen so
enderple egal ich würde sagen ich lese
die Nachricht einfach in der nächsten
Folge dann zu Ende
weiter bisschen mehr 10 Minuten und dann
würde ich einfach sagen ja bis zur
nächsten Folge versuchen in den Griff zu
kriegen mit dem mit den les gerade die
ich habe ich guck mal wo es bei mir
vielleicht dran liegt oder ne und dann
würde ich sagen ja dann versuchen
nächsten Folgen sehr nice versuchen
nächsten Folgen wirklich an diese
Technik Sachen ranzuwagen und wenn es
nicht sofort klappt dann habt Geduld mit
uns wir sind nämlich keine wir Schau wir
zeigen euch den Mod wie ihr bestmöglich
eins son wir machen ein Let's Play das
heißt wir spielen das auch zum ersten
mal ne also bis zur nächsten Folge Ciao
Leute tschüss